Chi-square test for goodness-of-fit look at how well our observed values match
our expected values for a certain variable. For example, this variable could be
your response to the question do you like ice cream? Response one would be yes.
Response two would be no. But of course there might be a whole number of
responses for a particular variable like which season do you prefer? In that
case there would be four responses, spring, summer, winter, fall. But
chi-square tests can also help us determine whether or not two variables are
independent. In a chi-square test for independence, instead of just having the
observed and expected values in the two rows, we'll be looking at the number of
participants or subjects who answered response one for variable one. And
response one for variable two or the number who answered response two for
variable one and response one for variable two, etcetera. We're going to
illustrate the chi-square test for independence with a real research example.